c'était toi
j'ai besoin d'une faveur de plus
c'est la grande boîte à secrets pour garder
tout le monde en ligne et elle appartient à un
de nos associés
Yuri Nicolas tu m'apportes ce dont j'ai besoin et
tout ce que tu trouves est à toi je
vais avoir besoin de mon équipage qui  c'était un [ __ ] de
pote évident il y a un coffre-fort à l'arrière
emmène-moi
je pense que ce n'est pas une serrure horaire
je ne peux pas ouvrir avant minuit les flics les flics
viennent ici tout le temps c'est un diner
teleplay tu es prêt plutôt occupé en ce
moment
bon sang tu sais  ce que je dois prendre une fuite
toutes les unités se présentent immédiatement à l'emplacement
pas de [ __ ] de boules viennent de se montrer quelle est
la situation je pense que tu as dit mouston
je me dis que Gutzon reste cool
bien le flic serait le premier dans le temps
tu en as 30  minutes ou ta femme ton
enfant ta vie finie maintenant cette horloge à la
maison ça m'aide toujours à penser
je suppose qu'ils appellent ça une horloge de la mort
une fois que l'horloge était parfaite ils
chaufferaient l'horloge dans une pièce dans laquelle ils se
trouvaient remplie de  gaz toxique tous ceux qui ont
construit ces horloges sont morts  pensez-vous
qu'avant la fin, l'horloger avait la moindre
idée qu'il viendrait lui-même et sa
famille aussi